joining us now chairman of the Judiciary
Committee he led today's hearing did a
phenomenal job and I would say on a
scale of one to ten you and the Attorney
General get a thousand that list that
you went down that's the headline this
is over he's not changing his mind and
this is all beginning well to all my
friends on the other side we gave Muller
two years to do his job he had 19
lawyers he had 25 million dollars he
interviewed 500 people issued 2,000
subpoenas he had a plenty of opportunity
without interference the president gave
him a million and a half documents
everybody around the president and on
the president's campaign testified
voluntarily and here's what we know
there was no conspiracy between the
Trump campaign and the Russians at all
the Muller could not decide to press for
it on obstruction I always thought the
obstruction argument was absurd it is
over and the reason they're mad at Barr
in me is because they didn't get the
outcome they want my friends on the
other side want an outcome and they
don't care how they get it you know
senator I've known you a long time I
want you to delve into that line of
questioning that I played where you went
down your list fine abuse the rigged
criminal investigation into Hillary a it
was all rigged she did violate the
Espionage Act 18 USC 793 there was
classified top-secret information on
that server
she had an intent by deletions bleach
pit and hammers and pulling SIM cards
the intent was to destroy the evidence
the very thing that would be obstruction
which the very thing liberals are acting
like they care about that would be a
slam dunk obstruction case to me what
are your thoughts well what I tried to
show was it when it came to the Trump
campaign we had Bob Muller one of the
most experienced lawyers former FBI
director take two years 25 million
dollars 19 lawyers everybody in the
country believed he was a fair-minded
guy and he reached a conclusion that the
left doesn't like but the the verdict is
in for Muller know collusion
obstruction now what I tried to show the
public was that when it came to Clinton
Clinton's email investigation there was
no Bob Muller's involved it was struck
in Page who hated trump's guts wanted
her to win 100 million to nothing I want
the public to know that the FISA warrant
obtained against Carter page was based
on garbage collected by a foreign agent
paid for by the Democratic Party that
it's unfair if I'd to this day and I
want to find out did they open up a
counterintelligence investigation
against President Trump for bad motives
and we're going to get the answers to
all those questions you know I think
this is very important as well okay so
the issue of finding out whether they
rigged the Clinton investigation right
by the way is that the same time kind of
interesting the where did this originate
this crossfire hurricane important
questions let's talk about the FISA
abuse went out the New York Times
suggesting it might have all been paid
for Russian disinformation Wow
that's a big deal more importantly do
you believe as I do that a fraud was
committed on the FISA Court in the FISA
applications I read something was called
oh the Grassley gram memo that said the
bulk of information and the FISA
applications were was the paid for
dossier that might be Russian
disinformation is that true sir
well here's what I know that I know that
McCabe said that without the dossier
there'd be no warrant I know to this day
that there is no verification of the
dossier there's literally a bunch of
garbage and people certified to the
court that it was reliable I know that
call me the FBI director after President
Trump was elected gave him the same
dossier and told the president we can't
verify it we just want you to know about
it that doesn't add up we're going to
look at all that but here's what I do
know
nobody cares on the other side what the
FBI did or didn't do when it comes to
Clinton they don't care what they did or
didn't do when it comes to Trump they're
trying to destroy his presidency from
their point of view the rule of law is a
tool to get an outcome from my point of
view the rule of law protects us all
including President Trump including
Republicans you know something senator
you were there with the cattle I thought
you had one of your finest moments as a
senator and the Cavanaugh hearings
it was interesting there were a lot of I
believers on the most outrageous
allegation we have serious allegations
now about the attorney I'm sorry the
lieutenant governor of the Commonwealth
of Virginia rape and violent sexual
assault by two women I don't hear the I
believers I've heard I say that if
Donald Trump cured cancer gave every
American five million dollars tonight
and adopted the liberal agenda they'd
still hate him
am I wrong well I know you're right Ness
said because bipartisanship in their
world is to be nice to their people vote
for their judges sit on the sidelines
when they destroy a trump judge to give
Mulder the space to do his job it's not
enough when Muller gets an answer they
don't like he destroy bill bar bill bars
a fine man he'll sleep well tonight his
critics are the problem not him all
right senator thanks for being with us